a girl
so if you love a brown skin woman
I want you to help me sing this okay
Beyonce headlines her first concert in
four years and makes it a family affair
surprising the crowd with a cameo from
her daughter Blue Ivy I'm just blessed
Queen B hit the stage at the opening of
the Atlantis the Royal Hotel in Dubai
and while Spectators were told to keep
cell phones tucked away someone snuck in
a few videos
including when 11 year old blue joined
her mama on stage to sing brown skin
girl their grammy-winning song
[Music]
yeah that's blue in a red sparkling
Ensemble while her mom rocks a yellow
corseted dress for the sweet moment this
makes me feel strong and this makes me
proud and this makes me feel so lucky to
be a woman we are the ish I just feel so
powerful and I feel I feel fortunate
that God has given me this gift
Beyonce's concert comeback was a
star-studded event with Kendall Jenner
Nia Long Rebel Wilson Chloe Bailey and
Halle Bailey all in attendance Beyonce
is such a gracious human being and it's
easy to be around her and talk to her
because she's so kind and humble so I
mean how did we stop ourselves with him
you know I stopped myself by looking and
seeing and saying you know this is just
another wonderful normal human being
the singers production company Parkwood
entertainment shared her epic opening
number which included a fireworks
display before the queen bee herself
rose up from the floor singing Etta
James's 1960 classic at last
[Music]
Beyonce went on to belt out some of her
own Classics like naughty girl crazy in
love and Halo
[Music]
Mrs Carter then closed out the show with
her 2013 hit Drunk in Love
[Music]
yeah and at one point during the
performance she was raised 16 feet into
the air surrounded by a field of water
and fire
foreign
[Applause]